having a free society means that people
need to be free to take risks including
risks with their family when they are
suitable and loving parents every Amish
community has its own set of rules but
they typically shine electricity and
these horse and buggies as their primary
mode of transportation one modern
amenities they don't object to is
conventional medicine this is not a kind
of religion where you just say we're
gonna pray about it and hope that it all
works out
attorney Maurice Thompson represents
Sarah Hershberger and her family Sarah
was diagnosed with a rare cancer
lymphoblastic lymphoma last April and
the Hershberger's have simultaneously
been battling Sarah's cancer and a court
case since June the doctor said you know
right away Sarah quickly started her
first round of chemotherapy and the side
effects proved brutal Sarah's mother
worried for her safety some of the side
effects are the risk of death itself the
high risk over 50% chance of infertility
the risk of other kinds of cancer
manifesting themselves they decide that
they're going to pull her out in after
stage one is complete of the five stage
chemo and try a more natural herbal and
holistic treatment but the idea that
they could put her back into the chemo
the more invasive treatment if the
alternative didn't work natural remedies
may not be the appropriate route to
replace a medical treatment but it can
be a huge compliment to that treatment
integrative Lee health practitioner
Angela load they're agreed to consult
the Hershberger's regarding natural
remedies she hoped to work with Sarah's
doctor to provide supplements for her
treatment in natural medicine we know
that natural remedies can boost the
immune system and help the health
cells overcome the bad ones Angela says
the doctor was not open to considering
any supplements or alternatives and the
hospital eventually went on the
offensive Akron Children's Hospital
originally tried to have Sarah
Hershberger taken away from her parents
and Medina County Children's Services
flat-out refused to do that said these
parents are suitable parents they are
high-quality parents they're loving
parents and that's really key here you
know it's one thing for a society
government for experts to overrule
parents who are abusive or who are
neglectful or who perhaps lack the
capacity to properly care for their
children and it's imperative to
emphasize that none of those of the case
here the hospital didn't contest that
the Hershberger's were suitable parents
just that Sarah's interests would be
better served by the doctors expertise
the hospital then appealed the court's
ruling and the doctor testified that
Sarah required two full years of
chemotherapy to survive the hospital's
legal representative declined to comment
but argued the following in the
appellate court a finding of parental
suitability does not end a probate
courts inquiry parental rights even if
based upon firm belief and honest
convictions can be limited in order to
protect the best interests of the child
and that just seems crazy on paper but
this is actually with this Ohio statute
allows is for any person to step in and
say not the parents but I deserve to
make these choices for for the family
and for this person's daughter this time
the appellate court sided with the
hospital and appointed a guardian to
make medical decisions for Sarah
the Hershberger's feared that this new
guardian would force Sarah back into
chemotherapy so they fled they sought
experts in Tennessee they sought experts
in Mexico the Amish don't drive and they
don't take airplanes so when the Amish
have to go a long distance it's a really
big deal
we stay in the in the u.s. we knew when
I mean any hospital to the US they can
use Amtrak and Greyhound but you know
imagine how long it takes to get a bus
to Mexico
we actually they have spared no expense
in trying to find the most effective way
to cure
Sarah's cancer and Sarah seems to be
doing well she's actually she was like
my pretty healthy girl she was always a
fast runner she is the most vibrant full
of life energetic every time we see her
she is just glowing where when we first
saw her that was not the case there are
a lot of questions surrounding Sarah's
health and the future of her well-being
but because the Hershberger's have
repeatedly proven themselves as good
parents with absolutely zero trace of
abusive or negligent behavior Thompson
says these issues should be left
entirely to their discretion having a
free society means that people need to
be free to take risks including risks
with their family when they are suitable
and loving parents who will take those
risks out of position of love and belief
in the treatment that they're following
and that's what we have here and all we
can do is decide to put it in the hands
of the parents instead of government and
we're at otherwise we could take away
children from home schoolers we could
take away children from any religion
that we find offensive if we just be
left alone we're asking for the Guardian
has since resigned and Hershberger's no
longer fear forced treatment but
Thompson continues to work towards
preventing cases like this in the future
and intends to challenge this law until
it's overturned whether it's the right
to refuse unwanted forced medical
treatment or whether it's the
fundamental guarantees to raise and
bring up your child's in terms of their
education and their healthcare the way
the you see fit as a parent it's pretty
clear that the Hershberger's have strong
constitutional rights that stay
here and that's really what we're
protecting
[Music]